one of the brilliant things about
watching President Trump in situations
like tonight's Town Hall is that he's so
transparent take a look at this when
he's talking about Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer Brechin Whitmer the
governor in Michigan she's saying this
morning on TV we don't have the reagents
we need we don't have the swabs we need
she's still saying that she can't get
the testing that she would look we had a
phone call five days ago with the
governor's I was on the call with Vice
President Mike Pence has done a great
job he's the head of the committee of
the task force every governor there we
asked him what do you need not one
governor needed anything now all of a
sudden you see her on the Sunday I
watched it well we should get this and
we should get that should he get back to
running her state properly because she
should have brought it up on a phone
call okay so I love I love that that is
just classic Trump and he's there's
there's a couple of parts to that I
think first of all he's just so direct
you don't see that from normal
politicians they just never said oh just
I'm gonna tell you about the actual
phone call we had they'd give some you
know political answer but the the point
I really wanted to get your reaction to
Sarah because it came up in another
question during tonight which was from a
really strong Trump supporter who said
you're great we love you then you're
doing a great job but we're not we don't
sure we like all this aggressive
language either with the press or with
the governor's what do you make of that
Sarah when he's just really kind of
hitting back against governor Whitman
done it a number of times and other
governors what do you think well you
know I think that the people expect
president trunk to be President Trump I
don't think that's going to stop them
from voting for him those who support
him and you know in November come
November and what makes the difference
here as Steve is the fact that President
Trump isn't afraid to express how he
feels and that's pretty much what every
American is feeling so if he's talking
about Governor Whitmer and she you know
all the sudden is complaining and
politicizing you know after having a
phone call with him he's just gonna say
it like it is which is actually very
refreshing I understand sometimes people
can be put off by this because they're
used to politicians being politicians
but the reason President Trump was
elected is because he connects with the
American people and we know that he's
telling the truth and he's actually
fighting for us because he's not afraid
to say what's on his mind and I think
that makes the real difference here
that's right isn't it Matt I mean that
is one of the things that one of the in
a way one of the biggest changes aside
from all the policy changes is this
completely gonna reinvent it the way
people see their leaders sure and let's
just state the obvious here a governor
the governor of Michigan is auditioning
to be the vice president of the United
States and so whether things are going
well or whether they're going poorly
regarding the federal coordination she
exists to be a theatrical critic of the
president regardless of the support
that's been divided and if she's having
problems with testing maybe those are
her challenges in execution not the
federal government's challenges because
here in Florida it was just on Friday
that Governor DeSantis and I were
setting up a mobile testing facility to
build confidence where people could
drive through and get very rapid results
we're working with the private sector so
in those frontline industries people are
able to know that when they go into a
restaurant or maybe even a retail
establishment that they're dealing with
employees who have high health standards
and who are safe and I think that
allowing the states to be the
laboratories of those innovations and
really push forward with ways to build
that confidence ultimately will restore
our economy more quickly and I'm sorry
if they just haven't thought out the
answers in Michigan quite yet we're
doing pretty well in Florida I think
that is such a deep and true point Lisa
we get this endless it's like it's
become a mantra from the Trump critics
in the media and elsewhere we're testing
you know the disaster on testing but
it's just so untrue if you look at the
scale of the escalation in terms of the
production capacity there this is again
something the president spoke to tonight
again with another example of how
transparent he can be this time it was a
call from Camp David let's have a look
we have the best testing system right
now in the world I spent the weekend at
Camp David speaking to an and a prior
couple of days speaking to heads of
other countries that are desperate
for ventilators and we now have so many
ventilators you know a month ago that's
all they were talking about was
ventilators the team of people that did
this job was incredibly the biggest
mobilization since World War two I mean
this is the this is the point that I
just think they're not giving him any
credit for which is this the speed with
which they've ramped them it's not that
easy
when you actually look at the details of
how testing works to just sort of turn
it on and now we're by far the biggest
in the world the ventilator problem as
he said it's just basically no one even
talks about it anymore but I don't see
that the president is going to get any
credit from his critics for what he just
described there in terms of the
industrial mobilization to meet this
moment Lisa do you agree well hundred
percent I mean he never is right I mean
we we know this in covering the media we
know this and covering the Trump
administration he never gets credit for
anything and also just the the FDA
clearing red tape so that you can get
tests to market and that we can also
look at some of these therapeutics and
people using them under a compassionate
use as well and and I think the
conversation tonight is so important
because I think in this conversation
with President Trump and Martha and
Brett is so important because I think
for the longest time the dominating
question has been you know is it safe to
reopen the economy you know what are the
consequences of reopening the economy we
should also be asking ourselves what are
the consequences of remaining shut and
remain in close particularly when you
look at the economic calamity piling up
when you look at the mental health
aspect of this that even you know one
national hotline alone has seen a 900
percent increase in calls when you look
around the world and 130 million people
could be pushed to the brink of
starvation because of disruptions in the
global supply chain to food and also
because of the corona virus or you look
at you know polling you for small
businesses and a 40 percent could
potentially close their doors forever in
the next six months you look at or even
the health consequences of you know not
essential surgeries and things not being
allowed to take four to go forward
because of the excess as a priority to
the coronavirus so you look at all these
on
consequences of the isolation policies
of the shutdown and as it starts to pile
up we need to be looking at the totality
of the situation as you are making these
decisions moving forward and really
until recently that hasn't happened
exactly right well I I so agree with you
Lee so I said this on Twitter earlier in
the week which is that you know we're
really sick of hearing from all these
leaders about how they're following the
data on keeping the shutdowns going when
they're actually giving us zero data
about the public health costs of keeping
the shutdown going all the things you
just listed we're going to be really
focusing on that on next week's show as
well